[Applaudissements]
photo de groupe dans la joie 27
immigrants viennent de terminer leur
visite deux jours à saguenay la journée
avait commencé tôt dans cette aérogare
de montréal ces nouveaux arrivants rêve
d'un monde meilleur qui peut être se
trouvent en région comme cet homme qui
voudrait s'y installer et accueillir
plus tard sa femme et ses sept enfants
qui se trouvent toujours en république
démocratique du congo
dans ce cadre là le prévoit leur avenir
que je voulais trouver un coin calme où
c'est moins bruyant et en ce moment la
vie de famille tranquille
ou alors ce couple arrivé il ya un an du
mexique
[Musique]
c'est le départ vers le saguenay vol
organisé par la fédération des chambres
de commerce du québec dans ce projet de
plus de 3 millions financé pour
l'essentiel par le gouvernement du
québec près de l'arrivée quand
l'appareil sort des nuages
le saguenay se dévoile
l aéroport nos immigrants sont
accueillis comme des dignitaires par une
brochette de député et de maire de la
région
ensuite dans un hôtel des employeurs les
attendent des entreprises qui ont
véritablement des emplois offrir ces
immigrants ont été pré sélectionnés en
fonction de ces emplois disponibles
celui que tout le monde s'arrache c'est
lui georges binda pourquoi parce qu'il
est le seul à être soudeur les soudeurs
c'est une denrée rare
on s'appelle entre nous tu peux tu mens
pas si tu veux te faire passer d'eux
mêmes cette semaine j'ai reçu un appel
lundi dany ça me prend 6 ou leur
oppression demain matin j'ai épluché de
québec au complet pour la voir bonjour
ce n'est pas toujours l'appariement
parfait entre l'offre et la demande
d'emploi ma force et la communication la
création de contenus le branding ça
irait peut-être en vente mais
l'entreprise a surtout besoin d'autre
chose
ça et le soudeur
il est à la table d'à côté en train de
se laisser ensorceler par une directrice
des ressources humaines d'une autre
entreprise
amoureuse
georges binda est tellement sollicité
que les organisateurs de l'événement
doivent l'arraché à un employeur pour
l'amener au suivant
gabriel mercier dit savoir quoi faire
pour que l'intégration éventuelle de
georges binda soit un succès elle a déjà
embauché deux personnes de l'immigration
c'est souvent des gens qui ont des
parcours difficiles aussi les parcours
du combattant fait que je moi j'invite
beaucoup notre personnel à à s'ouvrir
être quelque part un peu protecteur de
ce monde là sa ponction attend jusqu'à
date la fonction
tout le monde est parti sauf georgeon
binda qui passe une dernière entrevue
d'embauché bilan de sa journée cette
entrevue et cette offre d'emploi
il faudra réfléchir et choisir ce que
pour moi le plus important c'est de
pouvoir m'intégrer de l'intégration pour
moi elle liée à une formation interne la
façon de travailler et se former ici ma
façon de faire visite rapide de la ville
pour montrer par exemple un quartier
résidentiel la maison moyenne coûte 175
mille dollars
c'est deux fois moins qu'à montréal on
peut louer aussi le saguenay jadis avait
des tours record de chômage
aujourd'hui on doit recruter du
personnel à l'extérieur ça permet à nous
les régions d'avoir accès à une main
d'oeuvre qui était à vie à montréal et
qui peut venir travailler en région qui
est prête à l'emploi
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu d'offre
formelle d'emplois pour notre couple
mexicain mais ils ont adoré saguenay
s'ils vont vous offre un emploi vous
allez le prendre
bien sûr le gagnant de la journée
le soudeur on sent que on est ensemble
le mail à
donc vous pourriez devenir un saguenéen
je le suis déjà puisque je suis là côté
du lac saint jean si c'est pas de l'axé
c'était bel et bien si tout se passe
comme souhaité georges en binda
reviendra bientôt travail au saguenay et
suivront plus tard sa femme et ses sept
enfants